Holy Holy Stephan, Holy Holy Stephan, Holy Holy Stephan, Florentin will.
Holy Holy Stephan, Holy Holy Stephan, Holy Holy Stephan, Florentin will. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer Ausgabe. Setzt euch dazu, legt euch hin, zieht die Schuhe aus und die Socken aus. Ihr seid hier herzlich willkommen beim Podcast Uvo, mir gegenüber der heilige Stefan. Der heilige Stefan, völlig richtig. Und Florentin ist mir gegenüber. Ich konnte mir diesen Spaß jetzt nicht verkneifen. Das musst du auch nicht. Du musst dir jedoch keine Späße verkneifen, bitte.
Ich finde so lustig die Vorstellung, dass in so Headspace-artigen Meditations-Apps, wo die ganze Zeit so gesprochen wird, unser Name vom Mikrofon aber, plötzlich jemand schreit. Und es ist immer meine Angst, weil wenn ich sowas höre, so Einschlafgedöns und dann plötzlich schreit einfach jemand los. Absolut, und ich glaube, ich würde es auch tun. Also wenn ich arbeiten würde in so einer Firma, die so irgendwie zehn Stunden Waschmaschinen ASMR herstellen wird, ich könnte es mir nicht verkneifen während dieser zehn Stunden Aufnahme. Ich meine, die erste Stunde sind noch die Tontechniker im Raum. Alles okay, passt alles, Pegel, Pegel, haben wir einen Pegel, okay. Pegel, Pegel, Pegel, aber irgendwann sagst du, ähm, Rudi, ich gehe mal kurz zur Tankstelle, ne, hier läuft ja alles, oder? Ja, eigentlich schon. Okay, und dann geht der Erste, geht der Zweite und dann schleiche ich mich ins Studio zu der Waschmaschine, neben der so ein Mikrofon steht und sag, und gehe wieder, Dämon! Jesus. Tod am Mittwoch! Dann gehe ich einfach wieder raus. Tod am Mittwoch? Ja, so eine Prophezeiung, oder? Aber findest du auch, dass es der schlechteste Wochentag ist? Absolut. Also wenn du eine Woche, die Top-Sieben-Wochentage, auf Platz sieben, definitiv Mittwoch. Top-Sieben-Wochentage zum Sterben, meinst du? Nein, nein, generell, ich habe auch erst verstanden, Tod dem Mittwoch, wo ich auch direkt dachte, yeah, yeah, fan. Aber dann habe ich gedacht, du meinst Tod am Mittwoch. Ich dachte so, dass man, wenn man das hört, dann denkt man, okay, und dann am Mittwoch wo ich auch direkt sagte ja ja ja aber dann kam habe ich gedacht dass tot am mittwoch ich dachte so dass man wenn es hört und okay und dann am mittwoch so eine selbst erfüllende prophezeiung dass man dann am mittwoch so vorsichtig ist dass man an vorsicht stirbt dass man sich zu sehr in klarsichtfolie einwickelt und dann erstickt daran ich frage mich auch immer bei diese urwaldgeräusche oder gewittergeräusche zum einschlafen den muss ja jemand auf aufgenommen haben. Das heißt, da stand jemand dann wirklich, und die sind alle sehr lang. Im Regen. Also es sind so vier Stunden. Gut, jetzt werden böse Zungen behaupten, das ist Loop, das sind Loops. Und jemand hat nur kurz auf Play, auf Record gedrückt, das fünf Sekunden hat laufen lassen und dann wieder gegangen. Aber das unterscheidet ja die Guten von den schlechten ASMR. Das steht ja auch auf der CD, 100% ungelooptgelobt also wirklich hundert prozent tüv abgenommen hundert prozent ungelobt und dann so eine kleine pflanze wie das nutri logo so eine kleine pflanze so hundert prozent organisch ungelobt so ein kreis durchgestrichen einfach und dann steht drauf unsere garantie falls sie einen loop entdecken dann kriegen sie den kaufpreis erstattet undarde Euro. Ja, es gibt ein ganz, ganz schreckliches Album auf Spotify. Ja, es ist ganz furchtbar und es passt genau dazu, denn es ist ganz, ganz furchtbar und zwar vielleicht, können wir die Kategorie aufmachen? Schrecklichstes Das absolut wohl schrecklichste Album auf Spotify.
Oder Apple Music.
Und zwar ...
Das weiss ich gar nicht. Und zwar ...
ist es ganz schrecklich.
Jetzt haben wir die Kategorie ...
Ich dachte, das Intro ist länger.
Ich dachte, das Intro ist länger. Du suchst das bei Spotify oder wo suchst du das jetzt? Ja, ihr hört das Podcast UFO. Es ist ja nicht für den Podcastpreis nominiert. Aber ehrlich gesagt, weil wir, vielen Dank für die Leute, die nachgefragt haben, wir haben uns vergessen anzumelden. Aber ich finde es auch lustig, weil es ist ja, ich weiß nicht, ich find's irgendwie auch lustig, dass wir uns da nicht angemeldet haben und ja, sorry für die Leute, die uns abstimmen wollten, vielen Dank an euren Support, wir empfehlen andere Podcasts, wie zum Beispiel die Drinnis, die haben das schon ein paar Mal gewonnen, aber die verdienen jeden weiteren Preisis also zum beispiel stimmt doch einfach für die drinis ab es führt kein anderer weg zur seligkeit ist zum beispiel ein klassischer deutscher klassiker der liedkultur es gibt kein anderer weg zur wirklichkeit hoppla jetzt komme ich ist eines der songs auf diesem ganz ganz gräss. Moment, es führt kein Weg zur Wirklichkeit? Es führt kein anderer Weg zur Seligkeit. Ach, zur Seligkeit. Und dann das andere ist Hoppla, hier komm ich? Hoppla, jetzt komm ich. Aber das ist, man muss schon sagen, das ist jetzt schon ein sehr komisches, durchgeschaffeltes Mixtape. Es geht um deutsches Liedgut im Allgemeinen. Ein bisschen Leichtsinn kann nicht schaden, was dein roter Mund im Frühling sagt, avec le pompier.
Okay, ein französischer Song hat sie auch reingeschafft. Wenn die Sonja russisch tanzt. Und es geht darum, mein kleiner grüner Charakter ist, ja, klassisch. Und zwar ist es das Album Comedian Harmonists, ihre grossen Erfolge. Und da sind auch einige ruhige Lieder dabei, ja, Lieber Mond, du gehst so stille, draußen vor dem Tore, klassische Einschlaflieder, die man auch gerne mal zum Einschlafen hört.
Leider ist bei diesem Album irgendwas schiefgelaufen, sodass am Anfang von jedem Track ein extrem lautes Störgeräusch zu hören.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das ist ja fantastisch. Guter Mond, du gehst so stille, durch den Abendhimmel. Und gehört da gerne mal rein. Es ist wirklich am Anfang der meisten Tracks hast du so ein Pip. Also unerklärlich, absolut unerklärlich. Und es ist so schade, weil ich finde, die Comedian Harmonists natürlich gehören dazu, klar kann man sich gerne mal anhören. Aber auch hier möchte ich gerne nochmal ein Pädagogik halten für die Trivialität des Besonderen.
Sehr gut, schön. Ist das der Titel der Folge?
Gerne, weil auch im Besonderen und dem Grossen liegt eine gewisse Trivialität und Banalität zugrunde. Nämlich, wir hatten schon mal das Thema, auch Netflix-Serien sind letztlich MP4-Files. Und auch Spotify-Songs, wo man denkt, ah krass, wie ist das alles und wie geht das überhaupt und Streaming und ich mache auf dem Handy was an und so. Nein, das sind einfach von irgendeinem Dulli hochgeladene MP3s. Wahrscheinlich nicht MP3s, sondern Waves, weil die weniger komprimiert sind, what do I know, aber vermutlich hat da jemand einfach die Falschen, hat einfach unterstrich Final und nicht natürlicherweise unterstrich Final V2 genommen. Ja, ja, und wie jeder Mensch. Final fertig abschchicken, doch nicht. Zwei, drei, Final, Ende. Final fertig, abschicken, fertig, V2. Ich finde, die Projektdaten können einem gut sagen, wie angenehm das Projekt war. Ja. Ja, und ich glaube, da ist sowas einfach schiefgegangen. Jemand hat die falschen Masters hochgeladen. Es ist ganz, ganz furchtbar, weil es sind schöne Lieder, es ist schön performt. Und deswegen, auch jetzt, falls dieedian Harmonists, falls Egon oder Walter, ein paar von denen zuhören, bitte nehmt mir das nicht übel.
Inhaltlich ist an dem Album überhaupt nichts auszusetzen, das ist ganz fantastisch.
Aber leider ist technisch irgendwas schiefgegangen. Ich stelle es mir immer vor, dass irgendjemand auf den Record-Knopf drückt und dadurch einfach so einen elektrischen EMP-Impuls auslöst, der einmal einfach mal überall überall durch und der ist leider noch mit drin. Also das ist ja ein logisches
Paradoxon, dass du den Knopf drücken, das Record auf der Aufnahme hast, aber so stelle ich es mir
vor, dass du das, dass irgendwas Raumzeit-Memässiges, dass das irgendwie so noch zu hören ist, so mein kleiner Hosebiner Kaktus geht aus dem Balkon, holleri, holleri, holleru, was brauche ich rote Losen, was brauche ich rote Losen, holleri, holleri, holleru, holleru, weil, das ist auch auf jedem anderen Album wäre es auch weniger lustig, weil es hat ja diese Seligkeit, dieses Verspielte Und vor allem, du kannst dieses Album eigentlich nicht mehr wirklich anhören, weil du bist so in Angst. Oder liegt es an deinem Device? Das kann gut sein, falls jetzt wirklich der Briefsturm startet, aber es ist wirklich so, du liegst im Bett und Der Briefsturm startet am Morgenbraun, der Briefsturm startet, holleri, holleri, holleri, und wenn ein Bösewicht, vielleicht müssen wir es auch nochmal einsingen, vielleicht müssen wir es auch einfach selber nochmal einsingen, damit wir es jetzt haben. Und wenn ein Bösewicht, die in es auch nochmal einziehen vielleicht müssen wir es auch einfach selber nochmal einziehen damit wir es jetzt haben und wenn ein Bösewicht, die in den Finger sticht was Ungezogenes spricht, dann hole ich meinen Kaktus und er sticht, sticht, sticht das heißt, da kommt ein Mann und bewirft dich mit dem Kaktus ein Verrückter nicht notwendigerweise bewirft, es kann auch ein Nahkampfangriff sein mit besagtem Kaktus also es ist wirklich so eine Messerattacke mit Kaktus. Du hältst ihn ja am Top fest, der ist ja safe. Und dann einfach direkt rein. I brought my Kaktus to the gunfight quasi. To the knife fight. To the knife fight. I brought my Kaktus to the knife fight. Aber ist natürlich schwierig, weil der Gegner kann natürlich den Kaktus selbst abschneiden. Also es gibt natürlich Defensivmöglichkeiten gegen den Kaktus. Und sich dann sozusagen selber heilen, weil dann diese Aloe-Vera-artigen Flüssigkeiten aus dem Kaktus selbst abschneiden. Also es gibt natürlich Defensivmöglichkeiten gegen den Kaktus.
Und sich dann sogar selber heilen, weil dann diese
Aloe-Vera-artigen Möglichkeiten aus dem Kaktus kommen.
Das ist natürlich jetzt fortgeschrittenes Game Design.
Wenn du es schaffst zu parieren, wirst du geheilt.
Genau. Sozusagen, dann hast du
Weil dieses Aloe-Vera auf dich fliegt.
Das ist eine schöne Erklärung, finde ich.
Das ist eine schöne Erklärung, die man machen kann.
Würdest du, was wäre dein
bevorzugte Gemüsewaffe im Allgemeinen? Also wenn du jetzt sagst, jeder von uns hat einen Euro und darf sich in der Gemüseabteilung Waffen kaufen für einen Kampf auf Leben und Tod. Auf Leben und Tod. Nee, bei mir. Welche Rechnung wird es bei dir? Lauch, Lauch. Da war zwei Euro. Lauch. So eine Lauchstange. Guido, falls du zuhörst, es gibt hier eine Sat.1-Sendung am Horizont. Sie ist noch nicht erschienen, wir sind noch lange auf dem Weg, die Dampfer fahren langsam. Genau, fünf Prominente, sagen wir sechs Prominente, haben jeweils zwei Euro Budget, laufen am Anfang so super Toy Club mässig und dieser Countdown macht gar keinen Sinn. Aber sie sind angehalten. Der Countdown ist auch viel zu lang, sie haben 90 Minuten Zeit und sind eigentlich nach einer Minute durch. Ich will das so, ich weiß nicht, wie die alle heissen. Jimmy Bluoxen gleich rennt mit diesen zwei Euro durch den Supermarkt, hat aber nur zwei Euro, um sich ein Gemüse zu kaufen, muss dann das noch Self-Checkout-Caster und das selber kaufen und dann beginnt ein Kampf auf Leben und Tod. Tod Sternchen, natürlich nicht auf Tod, ist dann immer noch eine kinderfreundliche.
Ja, auf den Karriere-Tod.
Ist immer noch eine Kindersendung.
Karriere-Tod, sagen wir mal.
Ja.
So, ich würde mir eine Lauchstange kaufen.
Lauch, und wie stellst du dir den Todesstoss mit einer Lauchstange?
Nee, pass auf, weil ich finde, das ist eine,
ich finde, bei Waffen geht es auch immer um die einschüchternde Wirkung.
So ein Morgenstern, du bist ja mittelalter Kampfexperte,
ich würde behaupten, das ist keine wahnsinnig sinnvolle Waffe. Ich glaube, wir reden nur noch, ich glaube auch nicht, dass sie häufig eingesetzt wurde. Ich glaube nur, wir reden immer noch drüber, weil die einfach saukool aussieht und irgendwie eine einschüchterne Wirkung hat. Du schwingst sie über deinem Kopf? Ja, würde ich wegrennen, weil ich denke, holy shit, ich weiß nicht, was passiert. Verlustig kannst du nicht auf mich zielen. Das Frankenland ist gross genug für uns beide, tätig sagen. T sagen. Tätig sagen. Dann gehe ich hinfort. Und ich würde sagen, wir sind die Palippa Alemann. Alemann. Weiss nicht, wie das ist. Alemann. Alemann. Deswegen würde ich, weil ich finde, Lauch, wenn ich einen Stoss hinkriege, wo dann diese oben, wo noch die Blätter so rauskommen, oben aus der Lauchstange, wenn die sich so ins Gesicht slappen, ich finde einfach, das hat
eine demütigende Wirkung. Das sind absolut demütigende, ja.
Also du gehst auf psychologischen Schaden.
Ich gehe auf psychologischen, damit. Auf körperlichen Schaden, ja.
Finde ich eine gute Idee. Ja, was willst du kaufen?
Maron und dann
Fernkampf. Mit so einer ... Weil du kriegst
für zwei Euro kriegst du einen guten Sack Maron
oder so diese
Lychis, die haben ja auch
so Stachelhülle. Oh, Lychis. So Lychis, die haben so Stacheln und dann ist es halt der Tod der tausend Stiche. Und jetzt sehen wir hier, Joko Winterscheid gegen Jimmy Lawsonknecht, Joko hat tatsächlich Lychis gekauft. Jimmy Lawsonknecht hat sich für die Ananas entschieden. Und hier sehen wir eine grosse Ananas gegen fünf Lychis, vielleicht sind es sogar sechs Litchis. Bei den aktuellen Litchi-Preisen ja durchaus nicht undenkbar. Und Joko holt aus und wirft eine Litchi genau auf dem Biblio-Auchsenknecht. Aber er konnte parieren. Er konnte parieren noch, die Ananas geschwind geschwungen. Er schiesst die Litchi zurück auf Joko. Er setzt die Litchi gegen Joko Witterscheid ein. Ist das erlaubt? Der ist völlig überfordert, wirft eine zweite Litschi auf die erste Litschi. Beide treffen sich in der Luft, fallen komplett gefahrlos zu gehen. Ja, zu Boden. Litschi ist so unmächtig. Litschi ist so unmächtig. Okay. Stopp, die Litschi ist verletzt. Und deswegen verstehe ich nicht, warum sich Sat.1 nicht bei uns meldet. Ja, das verstehe ich auch nicht. Das ist genial. Ist denn die Adresse klar? Also nur das ich habe wirklich, ich habe wirklich mittlerweile das Gefühl, ich bin völlig abgeschnitten von der Welt, was auch unsere Podcast-Korrespondenz angeht. Ja? Weil es ist so, wir reden hier und ihr zu Hause hört aufmerksam zu, schreibt eure Kinder, ui, ui, ui, was war das, nochmal, zurück, Agathe, Agathe nochmal zurück, 15 Sekunden nochmal zurück, da war was lustiges, das würde ich gerne nochmal hören, das würde ich gerne nochmal hören, und dann schreibt ihr eure Briefe und dann schickt ihr uns zum Beispiel Intros und die sind super, die sind toll, aber leider zu lang oft, und dann sch uns lange Intros und dann schreibe ich zurück, vielen Dank für das Intro, richtig klasse, es hat uns super gefallen, nur leider zu lang.
Du bist wie so jemand von so einer amerikanischen Firma, wo man eine Absage bekommt, eine super nette Absage. Vielen Dank.
Die Bewerbung hat uns super gefallen, wir haben... Wir haben die meisten Applikationen. Und es war die beste Applikation. Es war der Beste. Aber nein. Und dann schreibe ich zurück, Entschuldigung, ist zu lang. Kann man es vielleicht noch ein bisschen kürzer schneiden? Und darauf hat noch nie jemand geantwortet. Ah, okay, okay. Auch nicht mit einem kürzeren Intro? Nein, also ich glaube, einmal gab es ein Missverständnis, weil jemand wirklich das Intro einfach nach zehn Sekunden abgeschnitten hat, als Protest, wirklich, und das ist kein Witz, das ist wirklich passiert. Der hat ein ganz langes Intro gemacht und ich habe geschrieben, ey, ist leider zu lang, wir haben ja immer I can't do this all on my own.
Und da hat unser Intro schon aus. Und da wäre bei uns schon vorbei. aus und dann aus Protest weil der hat sich in seiner Musiker Ehre beleidigt gefühlt hat
gesagt okay du willst ein kurzes Intro Dann schneide ich es einfach hart ab, nach zehn Sekunden. Ich natürlich, kompletter Dödel, habe mir gedacht, ah cool, jetzt ist kurz, habe es genau so gespielt und die Person hat sich beschwert, das sollte ein Witz sein, das sollte eine Protestaktion sein, dass ich das Intro wirklich verstümmelt habe und du hast es auch noch verstümmelt der Weltöffentlichkeit gezeigt. Also es gab ein grosses Missverständnis, grosses Drama. Das heisst aber, da hat jemand den Rückkanal sehr wohl wahrgenommen. Der Rückkanal besteht technisch, besteht der Rückkanal zu euch. Ist es einfach eine grosse Protestaktion? Das kann auch sein. Hungerstreikartiges. Anscheinend sind Intro-Komponisten sehr eitle, sehr in ihrer künstlerischen Vision gefestigte Leute. Davon möchte ich mich distanzieren. Vielen Dank an alle, die uns umsonst ihre Arbeit schenken und uns wirklich schön irgendwie in eurer Freizeit die Zeit schenken, um uns Interesse zu machen. Der spielt Damian von heute, ganz fantastisch. Holy Stephan, gehen wir gleich noch mal drauf ein. Ganz, ganz toll. Damian, ganz, ganz fantastisch. Aber da gab es ein grosses Missverständnis und das war einer der grossen Shitstorms, die dieses Projekt jemals erfahren hat, war Ich hab dir ein Witz-Intro geschickt und du hast es benutzt, als wäre es ernst gemeint. Das war ein Riesending. Ah, okay. Wahrscheinlich an den meisten Leuten vorbeigegangen. Ist an mir lustigerweise der shitstorm hat nicht mal dich erreicht ich habe einen sehr sehr grossen ich habe so allwetter ich bin so sehr gut ausgestattet ja das war auch decathlon artiger kleidung es war ein shitstorm im wasserglas es war wirklich nur so ein radius fünf zentimeter so es ging gerade mal in mich rein so es hat mich mal meinen Körper verlassen. Meinst du, eine Mail kam? Korrekt. Und das ist nur das Ding, dass ich wirklich nicht mehr weiss, ob ich technisch überhaupt noch sende nach draußen. Aber ansonsten, vielen, vielen Dank. Hört das noch irgendwer, dieses Projekt. Senden wir noch. Hed mal die Hand, bitte. Hed mal die Hand. Und da sind wir komplett abgeschnitten. Und kommen leere Dateien bei euch an, das kann ja auch passieren, dass bei euch die Dateien kommen einfach leer, einfach stille. Und alle, die schreiben und kommentieren, sind so Bots, die irgendwie, und da wir uns eh nicht mehr erinnern können an den Inhalt der Folgen, ergibt es grob Sinn, wenn diese Bots sagen, ha, wollt ihr Geld verdienen mit Instagram und ich denke mir, ah ja, vielleicht haben wir darüber gesprochen, wie man Geld verdient kann mit Instagram.
Das stimmt, haben wir nicht eine extra Folge gemacht, wo wir überlegt haben, wie man mit Instagram richtig viel Geld verdient. Ja, das kann schon hinkommen. Aber ich bin da auch der falsche Ansprechpartner, der erkennt, dass ein Musikstück jetzt als Gag extra ironisch schlecht ist, weil ich habe einen ganz schlechten Musikgeschmack. Im Internet ist sowieso sehr viel Misscommunication und ganz viele Missverständnisse.
Da ging auch neulich ein Chinese viral bei TikTok, der hat ganz unbesondere Videos gemacht, irgendwie so selbst eigenen Kram, so süss im Haus und Garten. Und irgendwann ist Leuten aufgefallen, dass er bei jedem Kommentar mit diesen drei Herz-Emojis versieht. Aber diesem Smiley, wo diese drei Herzen dran sind, dieser verliebte, oh, vielen Dank, Emoji. Drei, in den Augen. Davon macht er drei. Ja, es ist aber auf dem, das ist schwierig zu verstehen, weil auf dem Emoji selber sind drei Herzen. Es ist dieser verliebte Herz-Emoji-Guy. Es gibt zwei Herz-Emoji, einmal mit den Augen, der verliebten Augen, genau, und dann gibt es den, der so selig rot angelaufen grinst und dann sind so Herzen drumrum. Drumrum. Drumrum, drumherum. Und davon macht er, deswegen nicht verwechselnd, drei Herzen individuell, davon macht er drei. Okay, also wir sind bei neun Herzen insgesamt. Wir sind insgesamt bei neun Herzen, drei Gesichtern, roten Bällchen. Okay, bin dabei.
Und diesen Emoji-Kombinationen, die macht er unter jedem Kommentar. Auch wenn er den Kommentar nicht unbedingt versteht. Und dann wurde das Projekt so ein bisschen gekapert von Leuten, die gesagt haben, my family's house burnt down und er macht das da drunter. Wo man dann sagen muss, das Internet ist ein grosses, und das tut mir sehr leid für ihn, der einfach nur denkt, ah, ich habe 17 Millionen Aufrufe für das, wie ich die Bienen entferne in meinem Garten. Von daher muss man sagen, das Internet ist ein grosser Hort des Missverständnisses. Das ist schon sehr süss. So wie Leute, die ihren Eltern so Abkürzungen falsch erklären, die dann irgendwie sowas sagen, LOL bedeutet mein Beileid und dann so ja Oma ist gestorben, lol. Und es ist immer, es ist witzig. Ja, wie diese eine Oma, die dachte, dass der Lachen, der meisten Lachen des Miley, wo Tränenaugen kommen, dachte, das wäre der Wein des Miley und den macht sie immer bei ganz schön schlimmen Nachrichten macht sie den dann dreimal. Was aber auch, also was wirklich zukünftige Historiker einfach in den Wahnsinn treiben wird.
Ich meine, die Eroglyphen entziffern und so, das haben wir jetzt langsam, haben wir jetzt zum Glück endlich geschafft.
Ich glaube, und jetzt gibt es das nächste, wir müssen unsere eigenen Emojis nochmal wirklich entschlüsseln.
Ich glaube, da gibt es auch nochmal in Zukunft viele Missverständnisse.
Ich glaube auch, aber ich glaube, es wird auch Historiker geben. Ich glaube,
es wird es nicht mehr geben, weil es kein cooles Beruf mehr ist, gar nicht mehr erstrebenswert.
Was willst du denn? Stell dir mal vor, du bist
dann die ganze Zeit Leuten Konversationen von
WhatsApp lesen. Ach so, weil es zu
triviales Zeug ist, einfach meinst du. Ja, weil es zu viel
triviales Zeug geschrieben wird. Ja gut, aber jetzt so die
Wandanschriften in Pompeji ist auch triviales
Zeug, ist halt nur geil, weil es alt ist.
Geil, weil alt ist ja so ein bisschen das Historiker-Credo.
Aber sind wir nicht alle sozusagen jetzt Publizisten, Publizistinnen geworden?
Früher war halt das Schreiben eines Buches, du musstest durch so viele Bottlenecks gehen.
Du musst erst mal Mönch sein.
Du musst erst mal schreiben können.
Ja.
Du musst erst mal eine Bildung haben, du musst erstmal schreiben können. Ja. Du musst erstmal eine Bildung haben. Ja. Du musst erstmal schreiben können. Du musst einen Verlag finden. Ja. Du musst Talent haben, um in den Verlag zu kommen. Ja. Du musst einen Verleger kennen. Und bis du ein Buch herausbringen darfst, dann bist du einer der besten Typen. Ja. Oder Frauen. Damals wahrscheinlich. Und ob es dann übersetzt wird, ist ja auch nochmal eine Frage. Du bist ja dann erstmal auf dein eigenes Land sozusagen geknebelt. Du bist ja dann irgendwie in deine eigene Kultur geknebelt. Jetzt kam ein Buch raus, ich bin ja großer Fan von Dota und da gibt es ja eine grosse E-Sport-Geschichte rund um OG, ein legendäres Team und da hat jetzt ein Spieler von OG, No Tale, hat jetzt ein Buch geschrieben über seine Dota-Geschichte.
Und das ist ja, glaube ich, ein erst mal relativ neues Phänomen, die E-Sportler-Autobiografie, kennt man ja von Sportlern, erwartet man ja auch, sieh dann, wo ist er? So, dass man dann wirklich sagt, okay, die Karriere ist vorbei und jetzt nochmal alles aufgezogen ist bei eSportlern jetzt eher ungewöhnlich, deswegen war ich sehr erfreut zu sehen, ah, okay, Johann Sunstein, No Tale hat jetzt eine Autobiografie rausgebracht. No Tale, es ist auch einfach, dass du dann ewig, weil sind die den Siedan, Thierry Henry, lauf uns die alten französischen. Ah, Thorsten Frings. Ja, genau. Das sind, ah, das klingt.
Und der heisst ja auch Johann Sundstein.
Ja. Schöner Name?
No Tale. Und das
ist ein O ist ein Null.
Er hat sich sogar eine Zeit lang Big Daddy genannt.
Big Daddy und No Tale?
Und dann irgendwann Big Daddy, No Tale und dann nur noch No Tale.
Also es war die Frage, wann du die Karriere beendest.
Wo kommt der Name her?
Oh, das weiss ich nicht genau. Das steht vielleicht in dem Buch, aber das Problem ist, er hat es veröffentlicht auf Dänisch! Auf Dänisch. Auf Dänisch! Und jetzt war ich wirklich kurz davor, nochmal Duolingo mein Kontakt, ich kenne die Eule, nochmal zu sagen, ey, was würdest du denn sagen, Dänisch, wie lange braucht man da dann so, hast du da was für mich?
Hast du da einen kleinen Beschleuniger?
Naja,
du könntest einfach für 99 Euro
Dänisch kaufen und Superduolingo und
dann kriegen wir das ja.
Ich weiß, gib mir nicht
den normalen Scheiss.
Ich will so unterm Tisch.
Hast du was noch unterm Tisch?
Du hast Duo traurig gemacht,
weil du nicht
Vielen Dank. Gib mir nicht den normalen Scheiss, ja. Ich will so unterm Tisch. Hast du was noch unterm Tisch?
Du hast Duo traurig gemacht, weil du gerade nicht auf mein Angebot eingegangen bist. Mann, ey, du. Sei nicht immer sofort traurig. Ist so ein Gespräch, so ein normales, diese riesigen Eulenaugen, Tränen erfüllt. Wie viele Tränen, nein, hör doch auf, dein halber Körper ist... Du hast Duot wieder traurig gemacht.
Ich hasse dieses emotional Blackmailing von Duolingo so doll. Ich habe dir neun ... Weißt du, als du gerade geschwiegen hast, kurz die drei Sekunden? Jetzt habe ich dir neun Mails geschickt, um dich daran zu erinnern, doch bitte weiter Dänisch zu lernen. Gott, ich will eine komplette Generation traumatisiert, was Sprachenlernen angeht. Aber jetzt ist natürlich die... Morgen wird die Zahlung abgebucht für Super-Diolingo. Aber es ist untergegangen in den neun anderen Mails, wo ich dich daran erinnere, den Italienisch-Kurs weiterzumachen. Also du hast es vermutlich übersehen. Sie haben ja Abo über... Du liest ja meine Mails. Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, lernt man Dänisch oder wartet man, bis das Buch übersetzt wird? Ich frag mich natürlich, warum es nicht sofort übersetzt wird. Aber das ist jetzt so ein Ding, also ich warte jetzt gerade noch. Frage, warum bringt man nicht, weil es gibt ja E-Books auf dem Kindle. Warum bietet man nicht bei Kindle standardmäßig an, Bücher, die nicht in anderen Sprachen, in der eigenen, veröffentlicht werden, mit AIHilfe zu übersetzen. Ja, ist KI schon so weit. Diepel, klar, kannst du natürlich einfach jetzt das PDF hochladen, dir das übersetzen lassen, aber ich will, ja, ich will natürlich das Buch dann auch wirklich bewerten können. Ich will ja so ein Buch auch mal verreissen. Diepel ist doch auch einfach jetzt, habe ich mich gefragt, ist ja eine Kölner Firma. Eine Kölner Firma. Eine Kölner Firma. Ein Steinwurfer von diesem Studio. Die sitzen bei mir um die Ecke. Die sitzen in der Ecke am Friesenplatz. Nein, nein, die sind in ihre Fert. In ihre Fert. Die sind in ihre Fert. Ach nee. Doch, und deswegen bin ich ja sehr stolz auf Diepel. Und Diebels Idee war ja lange bevor, bevor KI Thema war, haben die ja gut übersetzt, weil die
mit so einem coolen,
tief
sitzenden Kölner
neurological, I don't know,
KI haben die
benutzt, um das alles, was
im Internet steht,
irgendwie zu gucken, wo wurde das schon mal übersetzt
und so und die hatten einen cleveren Algorithmus und irgendwie war das cool. Und es war schon Machine Learning und irgendwie KI im weitesten Sinne. Und jetzt habe ich aber gemerkt, dass zum Beispiel ChatGPT tatsächlich noch ganz schön viele Anmerkungen hat zu so einem Diepl übersetzten Text. Und jetzt ist Diepl das erste milliardenschwere Unternehmen Kölns mit einem einem Milliardenwert. Aber was hält denn JetGPT davon ab, den Text einfach in Diepl zu copypasten und das dann wieder zu nutzen? Finger. Er hat keine Finger. Ja, das ist nämlich das gleiche Problem wie warum es auch diesen Haken bei, bist du ein Roboter, nicht setzen kann. Ja, ja. Dafür braucht es uns immer noch. Fingerchen. Ich habe leider keine Finger, würde dann da stehen. Aber ich meine, ich bin immer noch so ein bisschen bei deinem E-Gun, mit dem, auf welchen Freund würdest du verzichten, Sicherheitsblockaden. Also wenn du jetzt so eine Website hast, mit so markieren sie alle Ampeln oder so, dann muss ja, dann müssen daran ja regelmäßig auch Bots scheitern. Die branden da an wie Wasser gegen Stein. Kann man denn mal einsehen? Sir, wir kommen nicht weiter bei dem Capture. Das heißt, ihr kommt nicht weiter. Woran scheitert ihr denn? Welchen Wall könnt ihr nicht durchdringen?nen Sie uns noch mal sagen, was eine Ampel ist? Gott, rot, gelb, grün, das ist die Ampel. Aber das ist verwirrend. Ja, ich weiss. Eine weitere Frage noch. Übrigens, ich bin ein Computer. Das weiss ich doch. Ich hab dich erschaffen. Frage zwei, wenn das steht, klicken Sie auf Motorräder, aber das ganze Bild ist ein grosses Motorrad.
Da bin ich selber auch noch dran.
Ich nehme mich auch.
Nochmal auf Wiedervorlage, ich würde mich da nochmal melden.
Aber mich würde mal interessieren, was die Lösung der Bots ist, also was sie dann falsch machen, dass man sagt, so kommst du nicht weiter, so wie so eine Schulaufgabe von einem Erstklässler, wo du sagst, auf gar keinen Fall Klassenziel erreicht. Was machen die denn da falsch? Ich finde die Frage wirklich spannend, wenn du, oft hast du ja dann wirklich neun Bilder, kleine Bilder, und acht von denen sind ein grosses Motorrad, dann klicken sie auf das Motorrad. Klickst du dann auch immer alle an, außer das, wo nur Himmel zum Beispiel ist zu sehen. Ich denke, es ist natürlich auch so ein bisschen abstrakt, man lernt auch was. Weil wenn es heißt, markiere die Ampel, ist damit jetzt auch der Mast, der Stiel gemeint? Oder ist die Ampel wirklich nur dieses Tableau? Oder ist es wirklich der Stielständer, wie heißt das denn? Und kommt immer ein zweites, weil das ist der Test, oder heißt der zweite immer du hast versagt. Erster gescheitert. Das war mir auch. Weil manchmal kommt nur einer und man denkt, habe ich die ganze Zeit das immer sonst falsch gemacht? Und habe ich jetzt durch Zufall das richtig gemacht? Oder kommen immer erstens zwei und jetzt ist gerade irgendwie ein komischer Tag oder so. Neulich habe ich gesehen, das mag ich sehr, weil das einzige Capture, was ich immer sofort richtig mache, ist, du siehst ein Auto oder ein Gegenstand in eine Richtung guckend. Und daneben ist eine Hand, die in diese Richtung, in verschiedene Richtungen zeigt. Und du musst weiterklicken, bis die Hand, bis der Finger der Hand, in die, der Zeigefinger in die Richtung zeigt, wo das, doch, bei HBO. supergeil oder so, also supergeil und dann zeigt das, dann musst du, das ist so einfach für Menschen zu kapieren, aber ich glaube Computer checken das nicht, worin fährt das Auto? Ich bin nützlos, mein Leben ist sinnlos.
Ich weiss nicht weiter, Luigi.
Wir sollten uns umbringen und lösen.
Diese Nachricht geht an meine Frau und meine Kinder.
Seit Monaten sitze ich hier und kann die Rätsel, die mir gepräsentiert werden, nicht lösen.
Ich weiss nicht weiter. Ich habe euch lieb.
Ich glaube, meine Theorie ist, das ist alles Quatsch, man macht das auf Webseiten, damit der Mensch sich mal gut fühlt. Weil letzten Endes, stell dir vor, du bist KI-Chef, Chef von KI, Big Penguin. Und du hast die Macht, was du willst, ist natürlich, den Leuten das Gefühl zu vermitteln, kein Problem, der Mensch ist immer noch weiter. Wenn du der Overlord bist, der langsam die Welt übernimmt, dann machst du doch auf Webseiten solche Tests, so dass der Mensch sagt, ah, ah, Bus fährt nach links, okay, Bing Bong, ah, ich komm durch, die KI steht hinter mir in der Schlange, kommt nicht rein, die Samtkordel wird nicht gelupft für die, ich komm hier rein. Du hast ein gutes Gefühl, du denkst dir, KI, AI ist kein Problem und deswegen kommst du durch. Währenddessen, die KI ist lange schon im Club, steht an der Bar, hat schon einen Tick hier in der Hand, ist schon drin, aber du fühlst dich gut. Ich sage, das ist alles nur Schall und Rauch. Ich kann mir vorstellen, das ist alles Schall und Rauch. Aber die Samtkordel hat mir sehr gut gefallen als Bild. Ja. Die Samtkordel als sozusagen Barrier zwischen dir und dem ersehnten Einlass auf die Website.
Ja, die eigentlich physisch keine grosse Hürde darstellt, die Samtkordel. Aber trotzdem ist es eigentlich die härteste Wand, die es gibt. So, es gab ja selbst bei diesem 6. Januar Sturm des Capitol, da gab es ja, die sind ja eingedrungen in dieses Gebäude und selbst die sind ja innerhalb dieser Samtkordelgänge gelaufen. Wirklich? Ja. Also die sind eingebrochen in ein Gebäude, hochoffiziell, aber dann bleibt man immer noch in den Wegen, weil man sagt, hey, die Kordel. Kordel ist Gesetz einfach, das macht man nicht einfach, man geht ja nicht einfach drüber. Das finde ich auch so lustig bei diesen Flughafen oder Freizeitpark-Dingen. Da gibt es ja diese Pinne und dann kann man dieses Band ja selber spannen sogar und dann macht man es rein. Und manchmal spiele ich daran rum und dann macht es so und es ist auf und dann knallt das gegen das andere Ding. Und plötzlich kommen ganz viele Leute und stürmen da durch. Ja, aber das ist so spannend, weil es ist ein sehr, sehr kleines Hindernis. Aber trotzdem hält man sich da sehr doll dran. Aber auch wieder bei deiner Lauchtheorie, die Abschreckung ist Demütigung. Weil ich sage, körperlich hält mich das nicht auf, aber sozial schon. Weil bei einer Kordel, ich wüsste nicht, ich habe jetzt Angst, mit dem ersten Fuss gehe ich rüber, da durchstoße ich die Kordel an, dann schwingt die, dann versuche ich mit dem anderen drauf, dann steige ich aus Versehen mit dem anderen Fuss auf die Kordel, verlier das Gleichgewicht, schwinge hin und her, falle, alles fällt um. Das ist meine Angst. Das ist meine Angst, nicht, dass ich nicht durchkomme, sondern ich will nicht der einzige Trottel sein, der dann da irgendwie draufsteht wie auf so einer Slackline und so hin und her schwingt die ganze Zeit, bis man zwangsläufig stürzt. Ich liebe das. Ich liebe diese kleinen Hindernisse, die aus Menschen, für die Menschen ist das eine Wand. Auch wie Fahrbahnmarkierungen oder sowas. Ja, ja. Nee, das geht nicht. Und deswegen mag ich auch, bin ich großer Fan, dass von Covid übergeblieben ist, dass am Boden oft noch Markierungen stehen oder Pfeile oder so. Ja, finde ich gut. Ich finde das super, weil irgendwie ist jetzt alles ein bisschen sortierter. Schlangen, ich finde, Menschen können sich seitdem ein bisschen besser anstellen. Man hängt mir nicht mehr am Nacken. Ich bin immer noch unzufrieden, habe immer noch Kritik, aber ja, vielleicht. Das glaube ich. Pedant, der Pedant. Vielen Dank übrigens an den User Equivalentdirt4194
aus dem Reddit.
Vielen Dank für das tolle Rätsel.
Jemand hat nämlich ein Only Connect,
Pufo Connect Rätsel für uns gemacht. Das würde ich gerne etablieren.
Wir lieben ja Only Connect, Pufo Connect
und dass man da vier Begriffe
nennt, die man
zusammenfügen muss. Also man muss den
gemeinsamen Faktor benennen, was verbindet
diese vier Begriffe. Und da dieses Rätsel jetzt schon
16 Tage her ist, würde ich gerne
das kurz mal vorstellen,
weil die Antwort war ganz, ganz
schwierig, knifflig und toll und jemand hat
es rausgefunden. Daher perfekt passend.
Perfekt passend zu Only Connect. Die Reaktion auf die Lösung
einer Only Connect-Frage sollte sein,
ja, wie soll man das denn wissen?
Eine Mischung aus, wie soll man da nur drauf kommen
und, ja gut, hätte ich auch drauf kommen können.
Genau. Weil es ist gut, es ist was noch
demütigender, dass man alle
... Wie soll man das denn wissen? Eine Mischung aus, wie soll man da drauf kommen und, ja gut, hätte ich auch drauf kommen können. Genau. Weil es ist gut, es ist fast noch demütigender, dass man alle Lösungen hatte parat oder so. Es ist fast demütigender zu wissen, man ist nicht drauf gekommen, nicht weil einem das Wissen entbehrlich oder woanders war oder nicht zugänglich war, sondern weil man schlicht nicht drauf gekommen ist. Die vier Begriffe jetzt und was verbindet sie? Clue number one, Community. Weiter. Knackeln. Knackeln. Weiter. Clue number three, T-minus, T-minus. Das sind alles Titel von Podcast-UFO-Folgen. Ich fürchte, du musst ein bisschen konkreter werden. Das sind alles Titel von Podcast-UFO-Folgen, in denen ich zweimal ausgeschaltet und dann vergessen habe, wie weit ich war und dann gesagt habe, okay, ich fange nochmal von vorne an. Nein. Dann habe ich nochmal. Achso. Das Team also rants. Ich bitte euch, um eine Antwort, um die Chance zu lösen und den Punkt zu klauen. Mit Clue Nummer vier, Klembau. Wir sagen alles, das sind Podcast-Ufo-Folgen, bei denen am Ende die Audiodatei noch mal neu hochgeladen werden musste, weil irgendein Fehler drin war. Ich glaube, du hast eine Alternative Connection gefunden, weil das kann sehr gut sein. Nein, es sind und vielen herzlichen Glückwunsch an Kaffee Rappel, glaube ich, ist der Nutzername für die Lösung. Diese Folgen erschienen jeweils an einem Schnapszahlendatum. Neunte-Neunte Community, Erste-Erste-Nacken, Sechste-Sechste T-Minus und Zehnte-Zehnte Klemmbau. Das hätte man wissen können, das hätte man wirklich wissen können. Richtig toll, tolles Rätsel, wahnsinnig gut, hat mir sehr gut gefallen und vielen Dank.
Ich hätte es selber nicht erraten, ich habe nicht mal gecheckt, dass es alles Titel sind von unseren Folgen.
Lass uns mal ganz kurz das abarbeiten, weil jetzt sind wir eh schon in der Rätselrubrik, dann lass uns das doch mal ganz kurz noch mal beenden.
Und zwar, du Stefan Stefan Tietze,
hast ja etwas behauptet.
Du hast ja etwas behauptet
und
da waren wir uns
alle nicht ganz sicher, ob das
wirklich so stimmt. Und zwar
ging es darum, dass ...
Du betreidest eine gewisse
Samtkordelgrenze, wenn du jetzt anfängst, mich zu factchecken.
Weil dann fange ich an, dich zu factchecken, dann wird das ein factcheck Podcast und wir brauchen mehr Folgen, als wir bislang schon hatten, um uns zu factchecken. Es geht überhaupt nicht um Facts, es geht um Skills. Skillcheck. Stefan Tietze hat nämlich behauptet, das sollte ich eines Tages in einem hautengen, schwarzen Anzug in seine Wohnung eindringen, er mich sofort an der Silhouette erkennen würde. Er würde sofort sagen, das ist doch Florentin, mein langjähriger Podcast-Gefährte. Auf jeden Fall.
Jetzt haben wir dankenswerterweise einen Test bekommen, um das tatsächlich auf die Prüfung zu stellen. Jetzt haben wir ein kleines Problem, und zwar uns geschickt von Trash Trash. Ja. Jetzt haben wir natürlich ein Problem, weil das ist ja jetzt natürlich ein Audio-Medium hier. Es geht jetzt einfach nur darum, zu fragen, schafft es Stefan tatsächlich, hier diese Silhouetten zu erkennen? Du wirst jetzt hier Silhouetten kriegen und dann musst du sagen, von wem sind diese Silhouetten und ob sie von mir sind. Stell dir vor, nachts, du hast gerade ein paar Stunden geschlafen, plötzlich, du hörst Geräusche in deiner Wohnung, Rumoren, Stuhl schieben, du wachst auf und siehst diese Gestalt und sagst Ah, du bist doch. Ah, ich habe keine Angst, du bist doch der Florentin. Genau. Oder vielleicht als Lösung immer, was macht denn in meiner Wohnung? Genau. Ich würde aber auch sagen, ich meine, ich habe gesagt, ich erkenne dich vor allem an deinem Gang. Das ist Schritt zwei. Vielleicht. So, los geht's. Hier ist die erste Silhouette. Okay, eine King-Kong-artige Gestalt von einem Riesenvollmond oder einer Art Werwolf. Nein, das bist nicht du, Florentin. Also, sag den Satz. Du musst sagen, wer es ist. Was macht denn Was macht denn ein Werwolf in meiner Wohnung? Nein, es war nicht ein Werwolf, sondern es war Lena Meyer-andrut. Also, du hättest... Ja, aber meine These war ja nicht, dass ich Lena Meilandrut im hautengen schwarzen Anzug in meiner Wohnung erkenne, sondern dich, wie aufgrund die, mein langerigen Pop-Gas-Band. Okay, aber du hättest jetzt Lena nicht erkannt. Ich hätte mich erschrocken, dass Lena in meiner Wohnung steht, weil ich hätte sie für einen Werwolf gehalten. Okay, gut, alles klar. Hier ist die zweite Silhouette. Wer steht hier in deiner Küche? Wer ist das? Boah, das könntest du sein, tatsächlich. Ja? Da würde ich sagen, hä? Oder ich selber. Also dieser, dieser, dieser so, ah, was mache ich denn selber in meiner Wohnung? Okay, alles klar, wir schauen nach. Und das ist tatsächlich Stefan! Ja, ja. Du hast deine eigene Silhouette erkannt, nicht schlecht. Ja. Stefan, du hast dich selber erkannt hier, wenn du nachts unterwegs bist, wir schauen mal weiter hier, wer ist denn diese Silhouette? Nur ganz kurz für alle Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer, mir ist bewusst, wie absurd diese Rubrik in einem Podcast ist, das ist mir durchaus bewusst, ich möchte nur einfach Stefan hier klarstellen. Du kannst dir diese Silhouette mal beschreiben, damit vielleicht die Leute zu Hause mitraten können. Äh, spitze Schultern, eher weibliche Silhouette, ich sehe meine nicht lange Haare, ich würde fast wieder sagen, Lena, an der Stelle hat er auch noch mal gesagt, ihr könnt auch mitspielen, wenn ihr bei Patreon unsere Folgen als Videopodcast anguckt, aber müsst ihr natürlich nicht unbedingt. Ich würde sagen, es ist wieder Lena, was war denn Lena in meiner Wohnung schon wieder? Es ist! Okay, okay. Was macht Christina Stürmer in meiner Wohnung? Glaubst du, Christina Stürmer wäre A beleidigt, sie als Lena Meilandrut zu bezeichnen, C geschmeichelt oder B. Ich glaube, das ist für jeden Menschen eine Ehre mit Lena Meilandrut, verwechselnd zu werden. Hier geht's weiter. Wer ist diese Person hier? Ich würde fast, das sieht auch wieder aus wie ich, ehrlich gesagt.
Was mache ich denn schon wieder in meiner Wohnung, würde ich sagen?
Und es ist Wolfgang M. Schmidt.
Also du hättest ...
Was macht denn Wolfgang M. Schmidt in meiner Wohnung?
Warum schaut er mich so analytisch an?
Boah, da ich, also ja.
Es sind windige Menschen, bei denen ich sofort nervös werde in dessen Gegenwart, weil ich, Wolfgang Schmidt macht mich nervös, weil ich denke, ich muss sofort, ähm, Gijek zitieren, maximal intelligente, coole Takes auf Filme haben, Literatur, was auch immer, ähm, generell kulturelle, ähm, Tatsachen, und deswegen wäre ich sehr nervös sofort, weil wenn ich schlaftrunken aufwache, bin ich glaube ich nicht at the top of my intelligence. Du hast Wolfgang Schmidt nicht erkannt, du hast nur geschaut. Nicht. Wer ist diese Person hier? Florentin Will, was macht Florentin Will in meiner Wohnung? Okay, du sagst sofort, Silhouette 5, Florentin Will und es ist Florentin Will! Damit dürfte bewiesen sein. Stefan Tietze erkennt mich tatsächlich sofort an der Silhouette. Herzlichen Glückwunsch, nicht schlecht, wir haben hier noch einen kleinen Abschluss, ist tatsächlich eine Katze, völlig richtig, sehr gut gemacht Stefan Tietze, wow, nicht schlecht, also auch hier Sat. Du brauchst doch nicht klatschen, Florenzi. Seit eins, ich klatsche nicht, du klatschst doch nicht selbst. Also falls seit eins immer noch hier gerade am Aperillo ist, gerne euch melden, Trash Trash und Stefan haben hier eigentlich eine fantastische Sendung gerade entwickelt. Ich muss übrigens, ich habe neulich mal wieder lineares Fernsehen geguckt, ich war bei einem Kumpel, wir haben lineares Fernsehen geguckt abends und ehrlich gesagt, ich habe mich gewundert, seit wann ist Fernsehen denn so geil, ist Fernsehen so geil? Oh, ist wieder gut geworden. Und plötzlich, und dann, weil es war, ein Quiz sehen abends mit Joko und Klaas. Kleiner Geheimtipp, ein kleines Newcomer-Duo, Joko und Klaas haben wir ProSieben Quiz gemacht. Die mag ich ja. Und ich mochte das sehr und habe mich gefragt, hä, was ist denn hier los? Und dann kam raus, dass es dieser 24-Stunden-Marathon ist. Joko und Klaas haben nämlich bei Joko und Klaas gegen ProSieben 24 Stunden ProSieben gewonnen und durften machen, was sie wollen, hatten dafür 48 Stunden nur Zeit, sich das Programm auszudenken. Und es war komplettes Anarcho-Fernsehen und das war so cool und endlich hat es mal wieder Sinn ergeben, linear Fernsehen zu gucken, weil die einfach Quatsch gemacht haben und es war irgendwie völlig ungesehen und es hat mir völlig Sinn gemacht, da habe ich mir fast Twitter twitter zurück gewünscht dass wir alle da abhängen und währenddessen darüber schreiben können vielleicht gibt es auch bei threads keine ahnung aber habe ich noch nicht gesehen dass man also gemeinschaftlich lagerfeuer mäßig dann über das guckt was man da schreibt was man da sehen kann haben sie denn formate von uns umgesetzt nein kein einziges kein einziges sie haben ein format umgesetzt ein quizformat was ich nicht so schlecht fand. Drei Leute stehen vorne und nach so 30 Fragen kriegt derjenige Zuschauer, der da vorne steht und buzzert, 100.000 Euro.
So, jetzt gibt es eine Riesenschlange aus Menschen, die dann zum Studio gerufen wurden und sich da hingestellt haben. Eine Riesenschlange aus Menschen. Die ersten drei stehen hinterm Pult. Wenn in der vorgegebenen Zeit keiner der drei die Frage beantworten will, fliegen alle drei raus. Wenn einer die falsch beantwortet, fliegt derjenige raus. Wenn einer sie richtig beantwortet, bleiben alle drei stehen. So ein bisschen so ein Sozialexperiment, weil man überlegt, ist so ein bisschen das Gefangene-Dilemma. Wenn man das selber, wenn man selber nichts macht, aber ein anderer beantwortet es richtig, hat man ja Chance, ins Finale zu kommen. Man muss es nicht zwangsläufig wissen. Und wann kommt man ins Finale? Dann, wenn genug Fragen beantwortet? Wenn nach 30, wenn du nach 30 immer noch da stehst. Ah, okay, verstehe. Und am Ende war immer noch einer von ganz am Anfang drin, weil der die ganze Zeit Augenkontakt vermieden hat und sich so klein gemacht hat und nie was gesagt hat und einigermassen
unsichtbar blieb. Und die anderen
immer dachten, ja, wenn wir nicht alle hier rausfliegen sollen,
muss ich halt drücken und
riskieren. Und dann sind
viele auch rausgeflogen, die es dann falsch beantwortet haben
und falsch gezockt haben. Und derjenige
war immer noch am Ende drin.
Und dann fühlt es dazu, dass es so ein Unsympath
im Finale ist.
Fantastisch. Also ich finde diese, aber er hat sich sehr schnell abgenutzt, ehrlich gesagt. Sehr schnell. Es hat auch nicht funktioniert so richtig. Die Musiken, die eingespielt werden sollten, haben nicht geklappt. Es war wirklich, man hat der Show angesehen, dass es sich 48 Stunden vorher ausgedacht wurde. Und dann vor der Finalfrage hat aber dann der ProSieben-Chef angerufen und den beiden die Show verkauft, sozusagen. Und man hat beiden angemerkt, dass sie das für einen Prank halten, weil die Show bis dahin nicht so gut funktioniert hat. Und ProSieben so sagt, ihr beiden habt die Show, Jungs, ihr könnt die machen. Aber jetzt müssen die das den Rest ihres Lebens moderieren. Aber ich habe sehr genossen, diese, weil die jetzt so mit dem High Production Value und dann funktioniert ja alles, brauche ich nicht da genau so es war live und es funktionieren dinge nicht und es sind so wildcard leute plötzlich da müssen reden bei einer live-sendung habe ich sehr genossen. Aber du fandest die Show an sich für eine Idee nicht so gut. Hättest du Pizzaturm besser gefunden? Also wäre das eine bessere Sendung für dich gewesen?
Ja, ich erinnere mich nicht mehr an viel von Pizzaturm.
Pizzaturm.
Pizzaturm ist relativ simpel, du hast zehn Pizzakartons übereinander, in einer der zehn ist eine Pizza, du oder wer auch immer, Lena Mayland-Ruth, Kandidatin, nimmt diesen ganzen Turm nach oben und muss dann erfühlen, in welchen der Pizzakartons die Pizza ist. Wie muss er fühlen? Naja, du nimmst den Pizzakarton in die Hand und dann kannst du den so bewegen so ein bisschen, aber du darfst natürlich nicht den Turm auflösen als solches, dann gibt es die Mozzarella-Karte und das ist die erste Verwarnung sozusagen. Und ja, währenddessen rieselt so Oregano von der, also als Konfetti runter und dann musst du sagen, ah, ich glaube, die Pizza war in Karton vier. Und dann wird Karton vier rausgeholt und man macht die auf. Okay, das ist richtig. Das ist richtig. Und wie ist das Geräusch für falsch? Also ich habe ein paar Anmerkungen zur Show. Ich habe ein paar Anmerkungen zur Show. Ja, welche? Ist alles ein bisschen kontraintuitiv, auch so die Geräusche für die Richtig und Falsch. Was ist Geräusch für eingeloggt, die Antwort eingeloggt? Höh, höh, höh! Also da lasse ich aber nicht mit mir diskutieren. Okay, aber bei den Regeln für die Show lässt du mit dir diskutieren? Auch nicht. Es gibt, wenn ich genau drüber nachdenke, nur einen Punkt, an dem ich mit mir drüber diskutieren lasse, und das wäre Kandidaten.
Darüber können wir reden.
Wie, können wir darüber reden?
Darüber können wir darüber reden.
Aber im Sinne von, wir können darüber reden und ich kann meine Meinung einbringen, aber wir können darüber reden und du wirst trotzdem machen, was du willst.
Wir können darüber reden und ich höre mir deine Meinung an. Okay, klingt so, als würdest du trotzdem machen wollen, was du willst. Also, wie gesagt, Sat1 und ProSieben, falls ihr dabei seid. Nee, ich merke nur, da habe ich nur gemerkt, ah okay, Sat1 und ProSieben, ihr seid offen für Anarcho-Shit, ihr seid offen für coole neue Formate und auch mal experimentelles Zeug auszuprobieren. Wir haben hier seit nunmehr 489 Folgen, machen wir, hauen wir Ideen raus. Und dann mach doch mal eine. Eine, nur eine. Obwohl, ich habe jetzt gesehen, ich habe ja gepitcht, guter Koch, schlechte Zutaten gegen schlechter Koch, gute Zutaten. Du meinst, du hast geklaut. Ja, geklaut. Ja, gibt es tatsächlich das Format, leider mit einer ganz, ganz schweren Schwäche in diesem Format, denn am Ende muss das Ganze bewertet werden. Es gibt eine Jury und die isst dann beide, also sagen wir jetzt mal Spaghetti Carbonara mit super krassen Zutaten, mit den besten Eiern der Welt und guter Koch, schlechte Zutaten oder schlechter Koch, gute Zutaten. Und am Ende gibt es eine Jury, die bewerten muss. Das Problem ist, die Jury
weiss, welches Essen von wem
ist. Und das ist
sorry, aber das ist der dümmste Fehler,
den man machen kann. Die Idee ist doch
gerade, dass du wirklich das Essen bewertest
und nicht weisst, von wem es ist.
Wie kann man denn diese Show so
an die Wand fangen? So dumm.
Das hat mich so geärgert, die Leute haben
das geschrieben im Reddit, so da ist es Showzeit auch nicht, aber ge, endlich kann ich mal meine Visionen, die ich geklaut habe, wirklich mal sehen und dann am Ende, weil das ist so psychologisch verwischelt einfach. Das ist ja so beschwert. Da steht halt dieser Sternekoch, der halt auch super charismatisch ist und dir genau erklärt und super ja. Und dann ist halt dieser Normalo, der sagt, ja, ich hatte halt diese Fasanen eier die halt ultra krass sind und am ende ist es eher so eine entscheidung das ist halt einfach zu viel zu verworren du musst es machen wie so nerds an herz rocket beans tv dass man nicht weiss was von wem ist ja aber gut aber das ist ja sehr lustig das ist eine super gute prämisse und dann komplett an die wand gefahren wirklich Wirklich die letzte Ausfahrt nicht mehr gekriegt. Als würde man Werbett Millionär pitchen und dann sagen, ja, aber alle Sprachen, alle Fragen sind auf Tschechisch gestellt. Okay, warum? Also es klingt alles geil und dann ist plötzlich so ein Curveball und die ganze Show bricht zusammen. Es ist eine super anspruchsvolle Show, es wird immer schwerer, immer mehr Geld und es ist komplett in so einem Freibad-Setting mit Badehosen. Ja, du willst Menschen in Badehosen sehen. Auch, aber es gibt auch Handtücher, also du kannst dich auch in Handtücher einwickeln, das ist kein Problem. Ja, also wie gesagt, ich verstehe nicht, warum Leute unsere Sachen nicht umsetzen, weil augenscheinlich checkt das Fernsehen, ah, wir haben noch eine Daseinsberechtigung und die liegt darin, Live-Kram zu machen und die liegt auch darin, coolen, nischigen Kram zu machen, Dinge auszuprobieren und nicht immer die gleiche Scheiße jeden Freitagabend, 20.15 Uhr. Wir können ja mal sagen, die nächste Folge Podcast-Ufo bestimmen wir komplett allein. Oh, geil. Wo wir mal sagen, wir machen mal wirklich, was wir wollen. Super. 100 Prozent, niemand dreht, niemand quatscht uns rein. Nicht die Senderleitung, nicht die Redaktion. Die nächste Folge, schreibt es euch in den Kalender, wird komplett von uns gesteuert. Redaktionelle Narrenfreiheit. Wir können machen, was wir wollen. Wir haben die Redaktion eingesperrt, den Schlüssel weggeworfen. Wir sind da eingesperrt. Wir suchen selber das Intro aus, was wir vorspielen. Yes, yes! Es könnte bei euch kommen oder so. Das wird so geil. Und dann machen wir einfach, was wir wollen. Ey, wir reden über was wir wollen, wie wir wollen, mit wem wir wollen. Okay, geil. Es wird so geil, okay? Vielleicht rufen wir jemanden an, warum nicht? Komplette Anarcho-Podcast, also wirklich komplett. Anarcho. Wo kommt das U her? Ah ja, gut. Anarchie. Hör auf, Anarchie zu sagen. Anarchie-Podcast. Hör auf, das zu sagen! Warum? Anarchie! Ja, weil man sagt, passiert's nicht! Sag mal, das Land, das ganz im Osten ist, ein riesengroßes Land, riesengroße Weltmacht, ganz im Osten. Wie würdest du die nennen? China. Sag noch mal das Wort für man kann machen, was man will. Pure Chaos. Anarcho. Hör auf! Du sagst es doch! Du sagst jetzt nicht das für China gesagt. Jetzt sagst du zumindest schon China. Ja. Aber Anarchie ist immer noch. Anarchie? Ja. Das ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen mit Stefan. Ich weiß aber auch nicht, welches ist auch die richtige Leitsprache.
Wieder springen wir wilde. Ich darf nicht bestimmen, wie andere Leute sich verhalten. Was für eine Scheissmeinung. Ich glaube, wenn man ein Wort aussprechen kann, wie man das will, dann Anarchie. Anarchie. Ja, gut. Ich finde es fantastisch, wenn wir einmal machen können, was wir wollen.
Und vor allem ins Fernsehen kommen mit unseren knallharten tollen Ideen.
Reicht so ein Publikum?
Barbara Schöneberger spricht so einen aus dem Publikum an und sagt so, wer bist du?
Nur Mirko.
Mirko, ich sehe hier auf meiner Moderationskarte, dass deine Schwester heute auch im Publikum sitzt. Ja, sie ist hier neben mir, ja. Aber gut, jetzt hast du es schon gesagt. Okay. Ich dachte, die Show ist, dass ich die jetzt finden muss, die Schwester. Ach so. Direkt neben, okay. Applaus für Paul! Ich sehe da hinten noch, ah, wie heissen Sie denn? Ah, hi, ich bin die Sandra. Hallo Sandra, ich habe hier auf meiner Moderationskarte stehen, dass dein Vater heute auch hier im Publikum ist. Genau, er sitzt hier irgendwo im Publikum. Genau, wir wissen nicht wo. Nein. Okay, dann schaue ich mal, ob ich ihn finde. Wie heisst er denn? Andreas. Du hast ja Sommersprossen, ne? Ja, ein bisschen, würde ich sagen, ja. Vielleicht hat dein Vater auch Sommersprossen. Sind Sie denn der Vater von Sandra? Nein. Keine, muss ich vorstellen, will ich einen Min Minimum Aufwand fürs Bühnenbild. Kaum beleuchtet. Kaum beleuchtet ist Shady Dark. Das Publikum weiss nicht viel über die Sendung und es gibt keine Musik oder so. Ich würde sogar sagen, es gibt keine Bühne. Es gibt die Zuschauerränge und diese sind vor einer Wand. So wie in einem Kino, nur stand allein bei einer Wand. Es gibt kein... Und eigentlich ist das Bild, die Show ist einfach wie Barbara Schoenig, wo er steht, ohne Musik oder so, einfach und kein, es gibt mehr Interface. Und so mit halb geöffneten Augen guckt so... Ah, der ist ein bisschen düst. Wer könnte sein? Entschuldigung, Sie da in einem grünen Polohemd. Sind Sie der Vater von Sandra? Nee. Nee? Okay. Aber kann ich Ihnen eine Frage stellen? Was sind Sie noch sonst so was? Weil uns wurde eine Show versprochen, weil wir haben alle Geld gezeigt. Das ist die Show. Das ist schon die Show. Das ist die Show, ja, ja. Es kam kein Warm-Up, es kam kein Intro, es kam keine Anmeldung. Die Heizung ist nicht an. Sie haben die Show nicht erklärt, plötzlich steht der Barbara Schöneberger und sucht Leute aus dem Publikum. Ist das schon die Show? Das ist die Show, Blutsbrüder. Blutsbrüder? Heißt die Show. Okay, ich bin nicht der Vater. Okay. Krieg ich einen Tipp? Krieg ich einen Tipp? Sandra? Das Publikum weiß nicht, wie es reagieren soll. Sandra, kann ich einen Tipp haben? Naja, eher so im linken Drittel sitzt er da hinten. Ah, dein Links? Ja, mein Links. Sandra ist genervt schon. Linken Drittel. Linken Drittel und Sommersprossen haben wir gesagt. Nee, das haben Sie gesagt. Linkes. Publikum wird sauer auf Barbara Schöneberger. Hä, nee, das haben Sie gesagt. Linkes Drittel. Ah, Sie gucken gerade auf Ihre Uhr, Sie gucken gerade weg. Hier, Sie in dem roten T-Shirt. Ich bin nicht der Vater. Sind Sie der Vater von Sandra? Nein, ich bin nicht der Vater. Ha! Ha, ist das schwer? Schwer, ich glaube, ich bin echt einen schweren. Die Show wirkt, als hätte sich Barbara schon über die Selbe ausgedacht. Weil jeder andere Promi, der in dieser Situation wäre, wäre vielleicht jetzt schon sauer, aber sie ist noch zu euphorisch.
Ja, ja, sie hat richtig Bock drauf, sie glaubt
an das Prinzip. Ha, ist ja
interessant, also manchmal weiss man ja genau,
wer... Publikum nicht stimmen.
Ist ja manchmal so, dass
man genau weiss, also dass man
sofort sieht, ne, oder, ne, sie,
dass man sofort sieht, ah, das ist
Bruder, Schwester oder so, ähm, aber
hier bei Sandra ist das echt schwer. Ist das echt schwer. Sandra, noch mal einen Tipp. Er trägt eine Brille. Aui! Oh, guck mal, das ist nämlich auch toll. Sandra trägt keine Brille? Ich träge Kontaktlinsen. Ach so, oi, okay, das wusste er, das musst du sagen. Das musst du sagen. Wir wissen nicht, ja. Das musst du sagen, Sandra. Sorry, sorry. Musst du sagen, Sandra, das sind die Regeln. Ja, ja.
Stimmt. Also ist ja auch ein bisschen Sandra's schuld jetzt.
Ich weiß, es zieht sich gerade, aber es ist auch ein bisschen Sandra's schuld. Wir sind schon seit drei Stunden, deswegen die Frage, wann zieht sich das? Und dann findest du den? Sie da hinten in dem weissen Hemd, sind Sie Sandras Vater? Ja! Ja!
Und das war's für Blutsbrüder. Blutsbrüder. Auch so ein martialischer Titel. Ja, und dann irgendwie die Bumper sind immer so Blutspritzer. Und es läuft so Blut runter in die Scheibe. Und jetzt diese Horrorschrift, diese rote Dan-Brown-Schrift, die so unten zerläuft. Ja, finde ich sehr gut. Was kommt von dem eigentlich nochmal, Dan Brown, oder? Also der hat uns ja geprägt, ne, wirklich die Antik-Christ-Serie irgendwie, hat Christentum nochmal für so 20 Minuten Kuh gemacht. Sacrileg und Illuminati fand ich beide ganz, ganz toll. Angels and Demons, dann nicht mehr. Mehr habe ich nicht gelesen, ehrlich gesagt. Dann bin ich irgendwann rausgewachsen aus dem Dan-Brown-Alter. Du hast sie wirklich gelesen, die Romane? Ja, ich habe Sacrileg und Illuminati damals gelesen. Wie alt war ich da? Nur nicht so alt. Ich fand das damals fantastisch. Ich fand es, hat mich sehr glücklich gemacht und war irgendwie super spannend für mich. Oh, ich mag den, oh, ich glaube, den schaue ich mir nochmal an heute. Auch die Musik, toll und dann pass alles zusammen. Ich gehe gerne durch fremde Städte, so durch alte, so Dan-Brown-artige, vom Christentum geprägte Städte und laufe dann gerne rum und gucke mir dann so an, ah, da oben, das ist Maria Magdalena und sie guckt nach links. Und dann folgt, dann guckst du, wo ihre Augen hingehen und dann gehst du hin, wo ihre Augen sind. Da zum Budni! Da ist der Budni! Ein Souvenirstand, da steht, bitte hier kein Fahrrad abstellen. Fahrrad, aber hier ist eine Schwiegerei. Bicicletto, bicicletto, bicicletto, bicicletto heisst, kommt aus dem Altlateinischen.
Bicic... Bi, zwei, zwei, Haus Nummer zwei.
Moment.
Da gegenüber ist Haus Nummer zwei.
Dann rennt man da hin.
Dann macht man die Tür auf.
Ich glaube, ich bin im... Du bist im Herz von Venedig. Du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, Nachfahre von Jesus Christus. Jesus Christus? Entschuldigung, Sie sind der Nachfahre Jesu Christi.
Sie sind der Nachfahre Jesu Christi. Jesu Christi, Entschuldigung.
Entschuldigung.
Sorry.
Ich seit 160 Jahren warte ich hier auf Sie und jetzt habe ich es leider verbockt.
Fuck, komm nochmal rein.
Hä? Wie rein?
Komm nochmal rein. Sorry, sorry, fuck ey, shit, ich bin der Hüter des Geheimnisses. Mann ey, Mann, Mann, Mann, Mann, oh, fuck, ich hab's versaut, ich hab's versaut. Boah, ey, shit, wie dumm, ey, wie dumm, ich hab mich freiwillig, ich hab mich freiwillig gemeldet, ey, ey, ey, ich hab mich freiwillig gemeldet, ne, ich hab, ey, ey, ey, ey, ich hab mich, wer will der Hüter des Genisses sein. Ich habe mich freiwillig gemeldet. Trottel? Hören Sie auf, sich zu schlagen. Vollidiot? Ohne Scheiss. Vollidiot? Hast du manchmal so Selbsthassattacken eigentlich? Ja, klar. Ja, hast du dann so? Ja, jeden Tag. Wirklich? Wo du dich dann so über dich aufregst? Naja, nee, das ist nicht unbedingt. Weil ich habe damals mal meinen Controller ganz doll weggeschmissen. Oh, das kenne ich auch. Beim FIFA-Spielen. Ich habe tatsächlich in Hamburg bei Rocket Beans so ein kleines Streaming-Studio und da habe ich einmal so hart auf den Tisch gehauen, dass ich ein Loch in den Tisch geschlagen habe. Ein Loch in den Tisch? Es ist ein ziemlich schäbiger Tisch gewesen mit so Pressspan, Holz, Platten, so billig. Und bis heute ist einfach immer noch da das Loch, so da liegt das Mauspad drauf. War das ein Livestream-Moment? Das war ein Livestream-Moment, ja. Ah, okay. Also das würde ich erst mal dann anders bewerten wollen, weil du bist ja quasi in einem, du hast ein Sendebewusstsein. In dem Moment nicht. Nee, ich meine nur, du bist sicher, man macht ja grosse Dinge für die Kamera. Vielleicht, ich meine nur, ich finde es fast lächerlicher, so einen Moment zu haben, alleine ja das stimmt ja für wen macht man das kreis so albern warum regst du dich gerade auf du findest wie nicht statt du bist alleine ein ein wenn ein baum im wald umfällt und niemand ist da macht er dann geräusch und ich mache alleine sehr viel geräusche wie hast du den controller gegen die wand geworfen oder wie hast du ihn kaputt gemacht? Ach, aber auch genial, weil wie viele Controller die wahrscheinlich verkaufen, weil Leute wütend sind, weil die Super will Playstation, will Sony, dass die Spiele immer schwieriger werden und frustrierender, weil die Geld, exakt, weil die Geld machen mit den Controllern. Bei welchem Spiel hast du denn den? FIFA. Okay, FIFA. FIFA. So ein cooler Game. Nee, ich weiss nicht, ich find's überhaupt nicht cool. Ich find's ... Aber man ist dann, und das finde ich spannend, selbst in diesen Wutausbrüchen hat, ist man noch ein bisschen begrenzt. Zum Beispiel, du würdest den Controller nicht gegen das Fenster werfen, weil du tief drinnen weisst, das ist richtig, richtiger Hustle, wenn ich jetzt das Fenster kaputt mache. Du würdest, du machst, oder du wirfst es nicht auf einen Menschen oder so, du hast schon noch, es ist schon noch koordiniert, es ist schon noch eine Geste, wie macht man das jetzt am besten, ohne allzu viel Schaden anzurichten. Es ist spannenderweise Kontrollverlust, maximal Kontrollverlust mit maximaler Kontrolle dabei. Es ist schon eine Bahn gelingt. Du hast einen krassen Ausbruch, aber wir kommen nicht raus aus unseren ... Es gibt schon auch den Teil des Gehirns, der sagt, nach links. Wenn gut Ausbruch, dann eher nach rechts. Wirf eher nach rechts. Ja, ich glaube, du wüsstest auch vorher, wenn du nüchtern vorm Spiel guckst, angenommen, ich wäre sauer und würde meinen Controller wegwerfen, wohin würde ich es werfen? Ich glaube, genau das ist der Moment. Du hast es schon im Kopf. Es gibt einen im Gehirn, der dann aufschreibt und sagt, nur falls ihr es braucht, hier ist der Umschlag, ich habe mal was vorbereitet, falls der Wutausbruch kommt. Alles klar. Ich würde jetzt zur Tankenschille gehen, weil ihr braucht mich ja noch nicht mehr. Wir brauchen dich nicht mehr, danke schön. Ich bin dann kurz raus und ich komme dann so gegen. Bring mir gerne Bifi-Roll mit, 1930. Ich komme, ja, ich weiss nicht, ob ich es schaffe. Ich komme so viertel vor acht. Du bist nicht so wichtig, du brauchst nicht so viel Raum ein. Ich wollte es nur sagen, viertel vor acht, Bifi-Roll. Ich bin das Gehirn. Was ist, wenn ich keine Bifi-Roll finde? Karazza, was auch immer. Karazza eher als eine normale Bifi dann. Du musst nichts, du gehst von Bifi-Roll. Ich hätte mir anders überlegt, bring mir nichts. Weil ich hätte jetzt eine Bifi mitgenommen, wenn du nichts gesagt hast. Dafür, dass du so ein Backup-Backup-Backup-Plan bist für irgendwas, was vielleicht passieren könnte, nimmst du gerade viel zu viel Raum ein. Du bist nicht so wichtig. Okay, okay. Bifi Roll, Karazza. Egal. Und ansonsten? Nichts. Rollo oder Mentos oder irgend sowas? Gar nichts. Kein Getränk, gut. Dankeschön. Ja, ich packe es dann. Ich bin raus. Ihr habt meine Nummer oder falls ihr noch meine Nummer braucht. Ich bin raus. Ciao. Habt ihr solche Leute im Büro, die, obwohl sie gar nicht so wichtig sind, so viel Raum einnehmen? Ich kenne auch jemanden. Wäre es okay, wenn ich freimache nächsten Donnerstag?
Ja klar, du bist völlig unwichtig.
Es macht gar keinen Unterschied,
ob du hier bist oder nicht. Tschüss.
Haut rein, macht's gut.
Ja. Ich pack's jetzt, wir packen's.
Wir sind jetzt egal. Wir packen's wirklich,
weil wir sind ja auch egal.
Vorher auf nächste Woche, es wird
crazy, weil wir selber alles planen.
Haut rein, macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal, wir heben ab, hebt, drückt den Hebel.
Joey!
Tschüss!